I'm gonna play for you this clip from
a major television network
and uh warning to all those you may have
heard it before it's disturbing
with her I'm worried about like her
mental
well-being and her dilation the minute
she leaves my house we have a dilation
problem that is a concern when you don't
have that watchful eye they tend to go
back to Old patterns I have woken Jazz
out of a dead sleep and taken the
dilator and put the lubrication on it
and said here you take this and you put
it in your vagina if not I will but jazz
is bad even when I'm home once a day I
will be so mad after Rasheed goes away
in college and that thing seals up I
bring her neck can you imagine this is a
story about a biological male this
entire discussion was beyond my
technical kin so let me explain let me
let me let me say it for you as plainly
and ineffective gentle but yeah all
right I am not going to explain this to
people in a way that will in invite
invective or aggression I will just try
and keep the language plain this is the
story about jazz Jennings a biological
male who at the age of three was
determined to be transgender by Jazz's
family began social transition around
seven puberty blockers hormone blockers
at the age of 17 as a minor Jazz
received which caught received uh a sex
change operation they referred as bottom
surgery typically an adult male received
what age 17 as a minor typically people
receive what's called a penile inversion
vaginoplasty if they're adults but
because Jazz underwent puberty blockers
Jazz did not develop any physical
function in in terms of sexual
components this resulted in severe
complications and multiple surgeries
where they take stomach lining to create
the inside of what is a permanent wound
in the pelvis of this young male the
purpose for which is so that a man who
is attracted to this to this to Jazz can
insert themselves for sexual
gratification
after the surgery because the wound
tries to seal itself you have to
introduce what's called a dilator every
day which is a a device that cranks the
wound open with lubrication this is the
story of a mother on The Learning
Channel a major corporate cable channel
explaining how she wakes up her
biologically male child in the middle of
the night and says stick this in your
wound and crank it open or I will and
then goes on to say if she leaves and
that wound closes I will ring her neck
tell me this is not moral Decay when on
cable television this which I believe to
be purely criminal child abuse is
celebrated I see that and I just say we
have reached a severe state of moral
decay
it's a kind of it sounds like a
psychosis
Collective psychosis and the idea that
it would be presented on any sort of
viable commercial television Outlet of
some kind
is staggering to me and you know Ron
DeSantis hasn't filed any criminal
charges against his family for what
they've done it's gotten to the point
where I'll phrase it this way if it was
uh 1990 and we heard a story about a
parent who did this to their child
they'd probably be arrested investigated
the child would be removed given
Psychotherapy and some kind of help
this is this is to this to the point
where not only is look
there are people in this country who are
mad at me right now for saying this this
woman says that she forces her child to
do this
her child clearly does not want to
that's why she has to wake up her child
in the middle of the night and say do it
or I will for a TV show and instead of
saying maybe we should investigate
because this sounds like abuse this
sounds like the child does not want to
engage in this practice and the mother
is making them do it and it could be
potentially harmful why don't we get
Protective Services or some kind of law
enforcement to at least investigate not
only are we not doing that we're putting
it on television celebrating it giving
them commercials and selling ad time on
it and their books and Jazz has a book
encouraging more children she's engaging
this jazz is an adult now which is why
there's no protective custody thing
going in now it's just you would assume
it's a consensual relationship between
two consenting adults otherwise Jazz
would have files let me play let me play
this other clip because people are
requesting I play this other clip here
well listen to this
are you feeling like
like to start talking about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
but you know I can't get out of my yeah
I know no listen it just doesn't stop
it's okay give me a hug it's okay I know
what you're going to we've been there no
weed still doesn't stop now and I'm
already going back to negative but the
more you're talking about yourself it
gets harder you're digging in and you're
it's making you put a magnifying glass
on what's already difficult as it is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy
I feel kind of all over the place and
like my mind is very cluttered and not
clear and I really want to have that
Clarity I really want to understand
myself and be able to read my own soul
and what I want and it's just very
challenging and I think I'm kind of
breaking down a little bit and spiraling
into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we ever
so
the interesting thing with this now is
that jazz a biological male who was
raised as a female underwent surgery is
dating women
this to me is is
obvious moral Corruption of our of our
society in ways we've not seen in
previous generations I'll tell you what
it brings to mind for me
it brings to mind
uh the statement from John Kenneth
Galbraith raise your hand if you know
John Kenneth Galbraith was he was an
economist he coined the term the
affluent society and he was also
President Kennedy's ambassador to India
and uh he and Buckley used to have a
kind of a relationship sort of like
Scalia and RBG where he had these two
people on different sides of the of the
issues who would debate and they were
best friends they would go skiing
together Etc but John Kenneth Galbraith
said I think around 1960 that America is
the first country in the history of the
world
where more people are at risk of dying
from having too much to eat than from
having too little and the choices that
and the decision making and the
Enterprise that you've just played
is is are the choices and decisions and
and the Enterprise of an elective
Society
where you know if you go around the
world uh or if you go into other
neighborhoods in the United States where
they don't have enough to eat
no one's doing this sort of thing
yeah I mean I think it's important to
note that this
was something that boiled up over time
right this this was something that uh
crept up to be at the point where we now
talk about it as if it's a regular part
of society Jazz's show used to be on TLC
TLC also hosted uh 19 Kids and Counting
which were Jim Bob and Michelle Duggar
who were these homeschooling Christians
and they were sort of another of you at
an extreme family because that's how TLC
made money for years and years and years
they took people who lived in sort of
unorthodox ways or not in a normal way
and put them both on TV and one of the
sons-in-law Derek Dillard on Twitter
this is I think this was in like two
thousand 16 maybe 2014. uh said you know
jazz is being abused this is not real
you know there's only two genders and
this is all terrible and TLC said he can
appear on the show anymore he is not
allowed to be on this thing where
theoretically he makes money uh because
they sided with the gender ideology and
this was I mean close to a decade ago at
this point we have seen this coming for
some time and instead of intervening and
saying like well let's at least have
both opposing opinions on air and let
people sort it out for themselves you
know I know you always say this but
people saw well this one makes more
money so we'll side with it I don't even
know if it does make more money uh but
there is there is a
when you look back it's sort of dark to
think that along the way we could have
had rational discussions and we could
have said I don't know maybe this is too
far maybe there are some boundaries
we're crossing and instead we're like no
we need to let people live as they live
even when you sacrifice a child body
basically when I saw Rachel dolezal
she was the lady out in in the Seattle
area I think who uh you know transracial
who became convinced that she identifies
as an African-American person
and you know took every step possible to
further that idea including changes in
the way she presented herself and so on
but she got as far with it as securing
the position I think of executive
director of the local NAACP out there
okay she she got to be in charge of an
organization for that advanced the
interests of of people of color even
though she herself was white and when I
saw that take place I thought to myself
well what should prohibit me from saying
that from the age of five I have
strongly identified as a beetle and I'm
going to demand that all of you anyone
who comes into my presence and and all
of you who don't shall now treat me
as a beetle that starts with the checks
but that's not the end of it right like
the bug yeah the sixth Beetle you know
um I suppose well there's the drummer
and then I guess you could say original
original Paul the first ball was the
first oh yeah I am the six millionth
font fifth Beatle is what I am but you
know
again these are this wouldn't this isn't
happening what you just played the Jazz
Jennings Saga isn't happening in in
places where people are scrounging just
to have enough to eat right these are
the decisions the elective decisions of
an affluent society and what's moral
Decay and it's just extraordinary are
you familiar with the rat hope
experiment no scientists put a bunch of
rats in a space limited space unlimited
resources food and water and then
observed what they would do and they
broke down to the point where
like they were uh huddling around each
other no longer engaging in normal right
Behavior one one group started grooming
themselves and did nothing else their
behavior started to break down they
became aggressive they would with the
limited amount of space they would all
congregate in one small area right they
uh the the social breakdown resulted in
like stopping eating and then dying when
they would take one of the rats from
this place and put it back into a normal
rat Society it would retain the social
behaviors and spread them and then bring
social Decay so that's very horrifying a
behavioral sync the rat Utopia I think
you may have said rat uh sorry it's a
different one The Hope was a different
one put them in water and make them swim
but it's the rat yeah hope one's scary
too yeah when you give people unlimited
food
you know how how do you convince them
not to eat too much thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time